ja und jetzt wünscht mir glück das ist
jetzt die finale springen wir das packen
wir ansonsten nicht okay bereits 210 c c
c server sex kids und herzlich
willkommen zu einem spielmodus den ich
bisher noch gar nicht gebracht war auf
meinem teller und zwar minecraft flash
zu spielen auf bergwerk web.de oder käse
funktioniert so ihr seht schon die
rasende mir vorbei man läuft mit speed
15 und machte damit sein kleines job es
gibt hier den instant tod der schon mal
ein trade mark von bergwerke labs ist
wer's glaubt wird selig aber es ist ein
sehr witziger spielmodus ich habe den
heute erst entdeckt und dachte mir den
probleme doch gleich mal aus dann gibt
ja diese checkpoints an die wird man
reset wenn man stirbt und jemand also
ich klicke dann immer schon wenn ich
weiß ich werde es nicht schaffe dann
klicke ich schon in der luft dann direkt
auf diesen button denn dann völlig nicht
so viel weiter fallen weil der respawn
nicht sofort kommt schickt man das
reicht nicht
der ist ganz tricky etwas kleinere runde
normalerweise dir bist du wie viel das
mir nicht jugend 16 16 leute darunter
hier haben sich jetzt gerade nur zwölf
gefunden für diese runde
und ich bin gerade bisschen abstrakt so
ein alter [ __ ] knapp ein bisschen meine
route der links runter man kann auch
noch woanders langfeld primär das leid
mal ausfällt ist das leichter und zwar
muss man dann von der zweiten rot gelben
hier geradeaus hier lang und kann man
hier rüber oder das deutlich leichter
einfach mach ich mir das leben so schwer
dass er deutlich leichter und jetzt
leute gebt mir das hier ich nicke gerade
kommt schnell ins nicken bin so wie ich
bin übrigens blog foss 14 32 am anfang
ist der spielmodus neid da kommt schon
am anfang ich den film modus sehr sehr
sehr ray plastik also es ist wirklich
nicht schwer da deutlich richtig
deutlich sage ich sehr krass abzuraten
weil am anfang ich mich sehr auf scheiß
modus evren dem und kacke aber wie
gesagt das ging relativ schnell bei mir
ich habe heute erst angefangen zu
spielen und mittlerweile geht es
eigentlich schon so jetzt gerade nicht
meine beste runde muss ich zugeben aber
es läuft also ich komme ganz gut zurecht
aber es ist nicht so wie sie das zu
kommentieren weil man sich halt
konzentrieren muss man musste sich in
einen vorsprung betreffen den da seht
ihr das system ist schon okay das wissen
über die amtlich irgendwie so die
konzentration aufrecht zu halten ist
nicht so easy jet set okay man hier so
jetzt probiere den ganzen käse noch mal
als konzentriere man dafür nicht die
konzentration verlieren
junge junge jetzt drückt mir die daumen
drückt mir die daumen
check point okay war da gehts weiter
ich musste mich gleich weiter ich habe
nen termin und zwar zum biergarten
dringend den biergarten nein obwohl ich
so weit war
nein junge dem ok so sollte man nicht
laufen weil dann rasch mehr direkt
runter ist es mit 16 ich weiß gar nicht
ob es ist ein sehr hohes fieber wie ihr
seht ja die die hits ist immer noch da
wie meine oma sein würde die hits es ist
extrem warm nach wie vor
und jetzt der dritte checkpoint finde
ich gut so ok also man kann auch locker
easy hier im schnieken langlaufen und
ist immer noch deutlich schneller als
wahrscheinlich sprinten ohne speed okay
gut passt so weit jetzt hier sehr gut
zumal auch über jetzt geht hier schauen
wir diesen baum hier hoch mit ein paar
löchern im weg ich nicht die ganze zeit
okay das erkennt der staat nicht so
anleger muss ich vorsichtig sein kann
man eigentlich sinken für so einzelne
module irgendwie von server seite aus
deaktivieren weil irgendwie scheint es
so als könnte man hier überhaupt nichts
liegen also nicht nach links nicht nach
rechts nach oben nicht nach unten
überhaupt nicht neues filter check point
und jetzt feine endspurt wir sind ganz
gut dabei wir anderen sind erst im
ersten modul so hier also ihr seht die
sprünge sind gigantisch dem komme hier
raus näher kann man nicht raus mit daten
die sprüche ist echt gigantisch leute
ist es verrückt ich bin auch hart
konzentriert also anmerkt vielleicht ich
bin ich rede gar nicht so viel und so
wie sonst ich bin richtig und
konzentration denn es ist nicht so easy
peasy de sie zumindest für mich mal
nicht vielleicht für andere sei okay es
geht hier weiter glaube ich
doch wie können wir weiterarbeiten wir
arbeiten das geht wir können euch hier
hoch
leister das geht nicht ich will endlich
diese runde möglich schnell zu ende
bringen das weg weil ich dann zu einem
anderen termin nicht zu spät komme
wenn ich ganz geil wenn wir das jetzt
hier mal ein bisschen regeln könnte
vielleicht sorgt ja jetzt wieder hier
unten
aber man kann von hier weiter muss nur
darauf springen und zwar so wie junge
junge junge okay wir sind darüber hinaus
so jetzt kommt ihr hier
diese command blogs geben uns ein jump
ist eine relativ krassen wie ihr seht
mal ganz locker hier hoch springen so
und ich glaube wir können sogar hoch jo
alter schwede dieser fing unruhigen eine
nicht so weit fliegen
jetzt müssen wir da hin und das machen
wir am besten so naja jetzt mit mir
glaube ich da unten in dieses wasserloch
wenn mich nicht alles täuscht dass man
erst mal so und jetzt wünscht mir glück
wünscht mir glück das ist jetzt die
finale springen wir das packen egal
ansonsten nicht okay 210 ccc cc c nein
angeblich da war nicht mein niveau wir
gelandet sind
kalter schiebung da waren nicht mal die
welt habt ihr das gesehen und ich habe
kein geld gesehen
ich habe kein lady penta gesehen und
warum schafft diesen sprung nicht da war
wirklich kein lilly pad leute davor
nicht euer ernst das hat der hagener
dieser letzten sprung sowie sie tritt
aber vielleicht kommt es hier schaffen
ich komme mal schaffen so jetzt nicht
die konzentration verlieren
nein man ist schwierig okay okay
komm wir können schaffen leute wir
können es schaffen
ich hab noch ich brauche wahrscheinlich
zu meinem termin 5 minuten
und der ist in acht minuten junge junge
junge junge junge junge aber es geht wir
können auch hier wird es schaffen und
zwar so genau
nice 77 11 okay leute vom staat zu
lieben fangen nicht an zu leben das
nicht gut für dich ja ja ja ganz auf die
spitze ganz auf die spitze damit ist
auch easy wird hier darüber sehr schön
ich würde schon sagen plan wunderbar was
jetzt möglich auch keine jetzt hier hin
ja kann man da ganz hoch taufe sind die
wolken bisschen stören
wir müssen auf jeden fall hallo sondern
ist auf jeden fall dahin nice nice nice
nice nice die wolken ich könnte
wahrscheinlich abstellen ich weiß nicht
genau wo ok dann unser ziel und jetzt
gibt es gib gas junge was jetzt hätte
ich jetzt schwören können dass wir jetzt
gerade da irgendwo gelandet sind aber
angeblich nicht okay nice nice nice nice
dahin ist das tier ist es die kunst
schaffen
wir können es tatsächlich noch schaffen
um ein ganzer linie dach und gibt gas us
blog foss 14.3 zweites spiel gewonnen
das sind wir leute das war's von meiner
allerersten folge fläche ab ob der
durchgefallen
wenn ja dann lass den daumen nach oben
da und probiert nicht nur das mal aus
oder schreibt einmal generell ein was
ihr davon haltet ist es unsinn kaka oder
geil ich gehe zum biergarten gelmini
kühe milch wir sehen uns